il ya quinze ans on m'a appelé pour
doubler un dessin animé
je n'avais jamais entendu parler puisque
c'était le premier épisode qui
s'appelait donc l'âge de glace et on m'a
confié ce rôle de diego en français et
récemment je me suis demandé quand est
ce que j'avais commencé en fait on m'a
annoncé que le premier était en 2002 ton
amour me dénuder plq est la prunelle de
mes yeux je suis pas content de
retrouver ce personnage adore sa voix sa
fantaisie sa folie j'aime toujours
autant ce personnage et je trouve que
même trois ans c'est trop long
tu vas faire ça tous les six mois je
n'arrive pas d'imaginer notre enfant il
serait le plus beau du monde
il s'est tu vois un peu de félins peu
gracieux mais un peu manche par moments
ça s'est imposé assez vite peut-être sur
le premier épisode on a mis un petit peu
plus de temps mais maintenant à chaque
fois que je reviens en studio et que je
me mets devant le micro ça revient assez
vite d'autant plus qu'entre temps il ya
des enfants qui me demandent de la faire
dans la vraie vie
du coup je la perds jamais de vue coucou
les enfants une fois qu'on a trouvé
vocalement le personnage après tout
roule
c'est la création qui est importante
c'est là où tu commences à trouver la
voie où es-tu guy-quint je vais parler
comme ça où je vais parler comme ça où
je vais garder ma propre voie je me
rappelle avoir testé plusieurs voiries
est vraiment que celle là qui
fonctionnait je sais mais pourquoi il
faut faire une voix un peu différente de
la vôtre
tout en conservant l'énergie de la vôtre
quand même il faut trouver une réponse à
ses partenaires qui ne sont pas présents
le jour vous le faites et il ya un truc
exceptionnel c'est les yeux les regards
parce qu'on travaille là dessus en tout
cas pour mon personnage à moi manille où
la trompe
évidemment cache la bouche donc il est
très expressif avec ses yeux et c'est
lui qui m'indique les solutions veux tu
être ma faubel pour la vie
sidi tombe amoureux sauf que début du
film s'est bien jeté par ça s'est fini
entraînions quoi propulse sur samba dit
toi ta photo de profil
quand on a des dents pourries comme lui
quand on n y voit comme ça qu'on parle
comme ça et qu'on sent mauvais c'est un
peu délicat de trouver des gens je sais
pas peut-être qu'il ya une application
spéciale pour lui je sens vrai j'ai des
dents pourries je cherche l'amour mais
c'est qu'avec toi que tu avais tout par
taille et je trouve qu'il a pris un
petit peu en sympathie diego est ce que
tu t'es toujours un peu en train de
râler
là il reste toujours signer que mais il
est plus impliqué on sent que d'avoir
rencontré cette jeune tigre est cela
fait du bien et ça c'est le gars qui va
nous sauver la vie qui manie très très
proche de sa fille pour l'instant elle
n'est amoureuse que lui et lui de la
même manière sauf qu'un jour elle
partira en mobylette aussi avec un autre
amoureux donc c'était très heureux de
voir manny devenir papa mais à partir du
moment où elle a décidé de se marier
la ja ja chez man est une espèce de
stress c'est ce qu'on aime dans l'âge de
glace c'est ce qui nous plaît à nous
adultes et c'est ce qui plaît aux
enfants ce qui a un double regard
d'enfant le voit au premier degré il
voit des personnages s'agitent est tombé
glissé de grandes montagnes s'exploser
etc
puis nous on voit du second degré on
voit des petites références en voie de
l'humour
donc c'est ça qui est qui est
intelligent c'est un dessin animé qu'à
son son univers son charme ses
personnages sont pleins d'humanité c'est
ce qui manque un peu dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui donc ça fait du bien de
voir des gens qui s'entraident c'est une
fierté de faire partie de la saga du
dessin animé qui a eu le plus de suite
ça prouve que les gens ont continué à
avoir envie de le voir les personnages
sont solides
non c'est fantastique l'âge de glace
les lillois de l'hiver
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un
un salut mammifères bonjour blake
bonjour au revoir mais je joue bien peu
des deux ça sert à rien mais la face que
ça fait pas à tant que ce truc
rachitique qui murmure à l'oreille de
diniz et qui fait un carton comme
danseur de salsa
[Musique]
von mally 12h08 je finirai sage hockey
et je reçois pauline cette politique
toujours là pour gâcher la fête
on s'en va les enfants n'oubliez pas
malade je chope ces voyous et je vous
ramène votre faux plat c'est un jeu de
mot ça soit pas mais je vous fais un
clin d'oeil à ce que je veux et un
manque de respect on ce qui est mauvais
sur et jolie je suis le protecteur de ce
monde perdu mes amis m'appellent tient
wesh liga voici mon message
on ne l'est pas rendez-nous de ses
affaires retournez donc chez vous lalala
lalala
je suis le plus grand ne vais pas le
méchant et tu es jurassique quand je
suis venue d'un stick
j'adore ce passage
et le voici le maître de méditation le
sérénissime
le quadruple champion du monde la pensée
profonde
[Musique]
c'est un lama j'ai horreur des lamas et
crache au dif salutations mammifères le
shangri-la ma va vous recevoir
[Musique]
sur le show et ça c'est le gars qui va
nous sauver la vie changeons de sujet on
est tous sur le point de mourir mais
c'est pas bon ça c'est connu le stress
tu relâches ont tous nos membres et
ouvrons nos esprits le chien tête en bas
il est sérieux là je peux attendre
rien ne presse j'ai tout mon temps j'ai
dit aux gars on se dit que là je suis
qu'à quatre mois et bégué monnier
dangereusement près du méfait
[Musique]
depuis la nuit des temps
nous nous demandons ce qui est à
l'origine de l'univers
un schéma merveilleusement d'orchestrés
ou quelque chose de beaucoup beaucoup
plus bêtes
ton amour me donne des belles tuer la
trouille de mesures veux tu être ma
faubel pour la vie c'est fini entre non
quoi en plus je ressemble pas du tout à
sa photo de profil
cette année je veux pas qu'on songe du
grand amour
c'est vraiment trop tu manques regarder
deux étoiles filantes vous et je vais
dire un mot j'y vois la ligne d'arrivée
oui toi petite ceinture y fox présente
aux saluts mammifères qu'est ce que tu
fais là
ce n'est qu'un début le plus gros des
astéroïdes se dirige tout droit vers
nous faut qu'on aille bien ou les autres
sont tombés qu'on cherche des indices et
qu'on trouve un moyen d'arrêter
tu es tu avec quoi crash il dit toujours
prêt au cas où trois compères nos
besoins ok misère mais trop trop classe
j'suis ferait pas un problème cher
franchement que tu es jolie toi
manny ellie sid diego buck extract vous
permettez casseurs d'ambiance la poudre
comme le petit déjeuner dans ta vie
l'âge de glace ville ou à toulouse vers
j'ai l'impression chaque câble oui je
confirme c'est complètement à part suisa
[Musique]
royan et visiteurs ne vont jamais lu de
visiteurs oh la la force et moi ou alors
moi surtout pas aux non attends je nous
vois solitude
j'hallucine ou quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe ici
j'espère que ce n'est pas
[Musique]
ce gars-là c'est sérieux ne laisse
tomber vaughn sans chanter moi c'est
brook nickel magnifique ossature cette
mâchoire puissant autres j'ai le coeur
tout chavire et j'ai l'estomac tout
retourné
au mit à mort tu ne saurait imaginer
combien deux dames ont essayé en vain de
dompter 6-2 les calots mais c'est avec
toi que je veux tout partager ton amour
me donne des pelles tuer la truelle de
mes yeux at 7 q j'ai trop mal je
t'arrête tout de suite tout est fini
entre nous quoi mais j'ai planifié que
notre avenir notre mariage nos enfants
notre caveau de famille ça va ou bien tu
es complètement personne n'a eu qu'un
seul grand café il a duré quatorze
minutes oui mais dans mon coeur lui n'en
a fait vingt ans je peux pas une bague g
vous sympa la bac mais non je peux pas
franchement tu es trop que l'enfant
comment charles coulomb
[Musique]
à ton avis si un problème ça le voilà
c'est le plus gros de tous les
astéroïdes croix sur nous vous permettez
c'est à dire on va tous disparaître bug
panic cette planète nous a dit la
solution ou doit aller là où les autres
météorites tombent chercher des indices
cosmique et trouver le moyen d'arrêter
toute assez crétin pour quoi que tu peux
arrêter un leurs théories de cracher dit
toujours prêt en cas de besoin confire
nos besoins la fin de l'âge de glace
pendant que vous prendrez vos pâtes à
votre cou nous ont frappés nar là haut
dans le ciel tous en sécurité comme ces
oiseaux
enfin presque tous ok misère mais que le
commencement c'est quoi cet endroit
deux villages ce train qui permettra de
sauver le monde d'ici shangri-la m'a
tuer des oui mais d'abord le chien tête
en bas
la posture du poulet mais je l'étais
gigote l'arrivée de quotas pour elle
mais diminuent dangereusement près de
mes fesses tu dis est century fox et
blue sky studios présentent aurait aussi
m ce sont ces gus là qui vont sauver le
monde
on est trop trop glace quand il est uni
japon charest pour quel tocard certaines
stratégies épisodes clés
de la plus grande frilosité tous les
temps l'amour me donne des belles
la truelle de mes yeux que je me sens
tout émoustillé je sens que je vais
dégobiller l'espace et des magnifiques
ça ne marchera jamais accroché voix
mobile
on veut un rack équipage ardue fait bien
fait et finalement pop
l'âge de glace les lois de bouteilles
le 13 juillet au cinéma
[Musique]